now I may have bitten off more than I
can chew trying to do reviews on this
thing
[Music]
Legion season 2 I have not talked about
Legion on this channel before it's
because ice basically saw the first
season a bit after it aired as I
eventually got around to cleaning out my
TBR and I liked it quite a bit it really
the show as a whole really threads the
needle very finely because it's really
hard with me to pull off a narrative
where I can't really adequately explain
what happened or what's going on yet it
still engages me and doesn't frustrate
me I think the key to it or at least the
key to it working in Legion is to just
have the right amount of clear points so
in the case of I'm just to start talking
about season two and less - I'm just
gonna say right now spoilers spoilers
insofar as I understand what is going on
because it's only j'en but I understand
enough to know I mean everything that I
saw last season which again I kind of
understand but there's a couple of
pillars that I can I can come on to I
know that these characters are aligned
together I know that these characters
are you know connected to each other I
know that David and the rest of the
people that he historically has been
friends with have a goal of trying to
capture the Shadow King and I know that
is what they are after and I know that
most of what they do is in the pursuit
of that goal so even if you show me a
depiction of something where I'm
watching what's happening yet I'm not
entirely sure what it means I at least
know their goals and the the reasoning
behind why they're attempting the things
that they're attempting so I can't truly
explain to you like say the dance
sequence in this episode in this
premiere episode of the second season
but I still like it
because it brings across the sense of
conflict between the three characters
who are involved in it even though I
don't really know what it means
it still feels consistent with as much
as I know about this show I get the
feeling that this season's gonna be even
more unrestrained than the first season
was in that way I think it has the
potential to kind of mirror the
progression of say Hannibal where the
first season of Hannibal was the most
grounded one because it had sort of the
more the most procedural aspects in in
it it wasn't it was like bonkers show
even off the bat but it felt like it had
to keep afoot in the more standard
procedural elements so that you know it
could kind of get people in and then the
second season once it had them then it
just started going nuts and I suspect
doing what it kind of wanted to do from
the beginning but I knew if it started
in that way nobody would stick around I
have getting that same vibe off of
Legion this really is going in whole hog
this is very much if you didn't see the
first season don't bother you have
there's there's not really a recap it
really does assume you have a sense of
what's going on it doesn't really
explain the characters and their
relationships you need to know how is it
this is not a jumping on point at all so
cast is all back I and it's a good cast
I'd like this cast I like these
characters I've loved Aubrey Plaza in
this show it's funny cuz I never got
around to getting into Parks and Rec
I've seen like a couple sporadic
episodes and she's buying in that but I
don't know her from that which seems to
be the big thing a lot of people really
love her from and I just I just don't
really know her from that I know her
from this and I love her and this she's
so she's the highlight for me she she
was basically since about the midpoint
of the first season when the whole twist
of exactly who and what she was came
through everyone else's is doing pretty
well and if I'm being completely honest
I do feel like the lead character of
David himself
I don't want to say he's a weak link
because I don't think he's necessarily
problem with a show he's one of the less
compelling characters he's one of the
ones who's harder to get a handle on in
terms of trying to relate to him
to a certain extent that might be by
design and I and honestly I'm not
entirely sure there was a way around it
because this is a guy who cannot trust
what he's seeing and who you know he can
try and relay his experiences but how
much of what he is seeing or feeling or
thinking is even his own and anything
that he is perceiving is can be said to
be real in any degree much less it's
more of an astral thing or a real thing
is very iffy and I think it's really
hard to embody a character like that
with a very clear and distinct
personality so I think yeah narrative
Lee he works but he is comparatively a
little bit of a bland lead and and and
Dan Stevens does well enough but ITT
tends to engage me more when basically
when he's really unsettled so like
really basically the breakdown episodes
of the first season were the ones that
really got me here he seems to be
rolling with it a bit more and when when
David's rolling with what's going on I
find him at hit to be his least
interesting visually this shows gorgeous
it was gorgeous last time and it shot so
it's just so tribute so like this is not
a show that you can watch while messing
around on your phone and doing other
stuff because if you're just mainly just
taking in the dialogue you're not gonna
get what's going on and you need to be
seeing this stuff not only for the
insanity but so much of the storytelling
is visual and especially in that it is
communicating in terms of mood vibes
general fields and the specifics in the
specific information it feels like there
wasn't that ton of it communicated
because the show at this point has
established so much the idea of how much
you can or can't trust what you're
seeing because it's being filtered
through David who is
a little bit a little bit unhinged and
so with with all that in mind you know
you're seeing all this stuff but you
don't know you don't know how concrete
it is you don't know if what you're
seeing is what's going on and even if it
isn't maybe it means something but
you're not sure what it is and like I
said like at the start of this review
that is really tough to balance and not
have it come off as either annoyingly
confusing stupidly obtuse or just
pretentious and this show is not any of
those things I really do enjoy this show
and it's as much as I have now just
rambled on for a while about the show in
general and a little and a bit about
this this second season premiere in
particular I have a hard time explaining
what's good about this show I mean the
best I can do is like if if I know
somebody in person I can kind of go like
you know what you told me you like or
what I know you like like you could get
into Legion or conversely I think you're
gonna have a hard time getting into that
one like I can kind of Intuit that but
to try and explain to someone like
YouTube subscribers whether or not it's
something that you'll enjoy is really
hard cuz you really got to be able to
zoom in to a pretty specific wavelength
but if you can I've never seen anything
else like this on television and I'm
really really glad it's back the the
wildness the trickiness of it the
abstractness and yet at the same time
feeling like it is telling a clear story
even if it's not being particularly
clear about it
I'm really happy this show is back cuz
it's nuts
and it's the best kind of nuts so
premiere episode for Legion season two
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about I do all that stuff such as
like and subscribe and buy t-shirts
support me on patreon whatever you feel
like doing links for all that stuff and
more is down in the description so until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]